[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit gundula
gause und marietta slomka guten abend
morgen ist er der nächste große
sondierungs tag wobei man fast ein
bisschen den überblick verlieren kann
bei den vielen tanz kärtchen die da
verteilt wurden erst trifft sich die spd
mit der fdp später dann auch mit den
grünen keine drei runden sondern erst
mal jeweils nur paartanz die union hat
morgen auch ein erstes treffen mit der
fdp die liberalen hätten das gerne
früher gehabt bevor sie sich mit den
sozialdemokraten treffen der symbolik
wegen das klappt aber terminlich nicht
wie es etwas verdruckst hieß thomas
reichert berichtet
das also ist einer der gründe warum die
union erst morgen mit der fdp sprechen
kann markus söder trifft sich in
augsburg erstmal mit csu provinzfürsten
erscheint wenig lust auf jamaika zu
haben und schlechte laune
reden intern alles gut behauptet so
dabei natürlich ist nichts gut weder in
bayern noch hier in sachsen anhalt beim
landesparteitag der cdu im osten hat die
union besonders viel verloren und
deshalb ist der ärger über
kanzlerkandidat laschet auch besonders
groß es gibt einfach unterschiedliche
befindlichkeiten der regionen und auch
unterschiedliche meinungen zu personen
die politisch in der lage sind sozusagen
ein land oder eben auch eine funktion
uns auszufüllen und die muss man
rechnung tragen immer heftiger wird in
der union nicht nur die kritikern
laschet und den inhalten sondern auch an
der art wie die spitze der cdu laschet
durchsetzte und in zukunft muss es vor
allem darum gehen wen wollen die
mitglieder oder auch wen wollen die
wähler denn wir haben ja gesehen bei der
bundestagswahl aber auch bei vergangenen
wahlen dass es ganz entscheidend darauf
ankommt wie die person an der spitze bei
der wählerschaft ankommt auch sie kam
bei der wählerschaft nicht so an wie
erhofft und doch bekommt annalena
baerbock beim länderrat der grünen in
berlin stehende ovationen ihre
kanzlerkandidatur ist gescheitert aber
die grünen können regieren in einer
ampel oder mit jamaika wobei dieses oder
immer unwahrscheinlicher wird man hat ja
eher den eindruck im moment dass die
cdu/csu sehr mit sich selbst beschäftigt
ist und für sich selbst nicht genau weiß
wohin der weg in den nächsten tagen und
wochen geht die präferenz für die ampel
ist bei den grünen überdeutlich und sie
haben sich erkundigt bei den kollegen in
hamburg wie das so ist mit olaf scholz
zu regieren vorhaben 2005 der olaf
scholz spd so kann man sich auch gleich
nennen eine regierung gestartet eine
kundin eine koalition gestartet und
haben wird und haben eben auch erlebt
dass und stolz uns als in kleinen
anbietet und im ersten zug eben auch mit
uns umgegangen
trotzdem es gibt an diesem tag keinen
der rote linien zieht nach 16 jahren in
der opposition treibt die grünen vor
allem dies um möglichst schnell eine
regierung bilden und es ja nicht
vermasseln tragen eine große
verantwortung für diese phase für diese
sondierung und regierungs phase und das
heißt für uns ganz klar
2017 darf sich nicht wiederholen wenn
wir uns nicht komplett nämlich
einstellen werden wir in den nächsten
vier jahren diese regierung nicht nur
mittragen sondern maßgeblich
mitbestimmen morgen abend wollen die
grünen mit der spd reden anfang nächster
woche mit der union sollte es einen
koalitionsvertrag geben dürfen die
grünen mitglieder darüber abstimmen
olaf scholz dürfte ist in nächster zeit
auch deshalb leichter fallen seine spd
zusammen zu halten bei den parteilinken
der rot-grün-rote traum weg geplatzt ist
da ist keine alternative option mehr mit
der man liebäugeln kann mit einem
forderungen der fdp nicht passen für die
linke selbst ist die bundestagswahl ja
tatsächlich im desaster geendet noch
nicht mal die fünf prozent hürde
übersprungen das ist bitter dass sie
trotzdem wieder ins parlament einzieht
verdankt sie drei direktmandaten 2 in
ost bezirken berlins eines in leipzig
heute traf man sich zur aufarbeitung
andreas künast über das scherbengericht
der linken
das alles war mal linksfraktion und
nichts ist davon übrig in diesem flügel
des bundestags wird kein einziger
abgeordneter sein mandat seinem büro
behalten alexander neu gehörte zum
fraktionschef der saar-linken linken und
sucht nun einen job und die gründe dafür
jüngere
gründe sind vielleicht auch die art und
weise des wahlkampfs da gab es die allen
die auf lager wahlkampf gesetzt haben
also rot rot grün über alles oder von
rot über alles auch ganz ohne inhalte
brauchen wir nicht hauptsache wir sind
in der
regierungsbeteiligung hauptsache
regierungsbeteiligung der vorwurf geht
an die parteispitze die spd und grüne
einen wahlkampf lang angepackt hat so
ehrlich und so deutlich wie selten sagt
sich der linken vorstand heute die
meinung einig wird man sich nicht
die ausrichtung auf eine option jeder
reist für diejenigen die uns brauchen
alle hebel in bewegung zu setzen keine
falsche strategische entscheidung
natürlich ist dieses ergebnis vom
letzten sonntag ein desaster für uns wir
haben flächendeckend
und massiv verloren und natürlich ist es
auch so dass man jetzt sechs tage nach
dieser wahl keine fertigen antworten hat
ein problem ist der wacklige
fraktionsstatus für den 37 sitze
benötigt werden die linke hat 39 treten
drei abgeordnete aus ist der
fraktionsstatus weg das thema platzt
mitten hinein in die trauerbewältigung
der fast halbierten fraktion weil
bereits ein mitglied mit austritt
gedroht hat
verlieren war eben den fraktionsstatus
dann kriegt man den gruppen status damit
muss er aber auch leben oder sie neu
ausgebrochen der streit um sarah
wagenknecht für die einen ist sie das
problem der linken für die anderen die
lösungen vor allem linke linke wollen
dass wagenknecht sichtbarer wird ich
halte es immer für einen fehler wenn man
innerhalb einer partei mit der man
solidarisch wieder umgehen sollte sich
von genossinnen und genossen
distanziert vor allem dann wenn es das
wirklich wert ist nicht davon zu
distanzieren das ist schon ne suis zitat
ein solcher ansatz was der
parteivorstand will wird heute nicht
klar nur was er nicht will dass sich die
linke ein weiteres mal zerlegt
jetzt gibt es erstmal nachrichten von
gundula für seine proeuropäische haltung
ist der rumänische präsident klaus
johannis mit dem aachener karlspreis
ausgezeichnet worden der siebenbürger
sachse stehe für die gemeinsame idee
einer europäischen zukunft und sei ein
brückenbauer zwischen west- und
osteuropäischen gesellschaften eu
ratspräsidenten michelle betonte in
seiner laudatio die gleichwertigkeit
aller eu-länder johannes erklärte er
sehe den preis als eine ehrung für ganz
rumhängen zugleich forderte er mehr
mittel für die bildung um demokratische
werte zu fördern
die britische regierung hat tausende auf
der insel lebende deutsche mit älteren
führerscheinen aufgefordert in der
fernfahrer branche zu arbeiten
das verkehrsministerium in london hatte
fast eine million menschen angeschrieben
die eine fahrerlaubnis für kleinere
lastwagen haben wegen des drecks it und
der pandemie fielen in großbritannien
zehntausende lkw-fahrer in den usa sind
landesweit zehntausende menschen für das
recht auf abtreibung auf die straßen
gegangen sie protestieren auch gegen ein
neues sehr strenges abtreibungsverbot in
texas das auch die us-regierung für
verfassungswidrig hält ab montag wird
sich der oberste gerichtshof der usa
damit befassen frauenrechtlerinnen haben
in 600 städten zu demonstrationen
aufgerufen sie rechnen mit bis zu
250.000 teilnehmern der umstrittene
präsident der philippinen dotierte hat
überraschend seinen rückzug aus der
politik angekündigt er trete beim
nächsten wahlen nicht an die bevölkerung
würde dies als verstoß gegen die
verfassung werden der 76-jährige
dotierte steht international in der
kritik wegen seiner extremen härte im
kampf gegen drogenkriminalität dabei
sollen tausende philippiner getötet
worden sein
angesichts wieder steigender corona
infektionszahlen hierzulande wird heftig
über die abschaffung der masken pflicht
an schulen gestritten dafür setzen sich
ärzteverbände 1 beschlossen ist ein ende
der masken pflicht an schulen bereits in
bremen thüringen sachsen anhalt und in
mecklenburg vorpommern sowie im saarland
bayern und berlin sie nach
dagegenhalten lehrerverbände und
virologen eine aufhebung der masken
pflichtschulen zum teil für verfrüht
eine hoffnung der politik ist dass das
so genannte 2 g modell manche doch noch
zum impfen animiert reinem pragmatismus
zweig heißt ja nur geimpfte und genießen
dürfen rein die bundesländer handhaben
das mal wieder unterschiedlich viele
bieten gastronomen zweig als option an
muss es nicht übernehmen man kann auch
bei 3g bleiben dann haben auch getestete
zutritt allerdings gelten dann in
innenräumen masken pflicht und
mindestabstände das also kuschelig will
wie in alten zeiten muss zweig wählen in
berlin das bekanntlich ein umfängliches
gastronomie und nachtleben hat wird
unterschieden restaurants und kneipen
dürfen ihr modell selbst wählen für
clubs und partys ist zweig jedoch
pflicht dieser jan die hat einen kleinen
streifzug durch die hauptstadt gemacht
und beginnt auf einer air berlin und
typischen partie
ja auch berlin kann oktoberfest in
münchen wurde die wiesn abgesagt hier
wird geschunkelt und gepostet erzählt
stimmung in der fischer hätte
man kann endlich wieder normal fahren
ohne dass man sich gedanken machen muss
für die musste es doch gerne einfach
hier wieder feiern zu dürfen und weil
alle sehnsucht haben am eingang
impfausweis kontrolle in berlin gilt die
2g optionsregelung heißt gastwirte
entscheiden wen sie reinlassen nur
genesene und geimpfte oder auch
getestete aber am strengsten ist es wohl
hier nur geimpfte
weil am oktoberfest sehr eng miteinander
geschunkelt wird getanzt wird deshalb
haben wir gesagt wir machen das nicht
wir machen nur eins geht weil wir wollen
nicht verantwortlich sein wenn jemand
danach ins krankenhaus kommen einsam ist
es im klub von famila showbiz wo getanzt
wird ist zwei geht's nicht und das
gefällt ihr nicht deshalb hat sie
vorläufig noch nicht regulär geöffnet
ich bin übrigens geimpft und ich
empfehle auch jedem sich impfen zu
lassen aber es gibt eben menschen die
einfach noch angst davor haben und durch
diese zweig regelung werden diese leute
definitiv ausgegrenzt und so ein
bisschen an den pranger gestellt wer
hier einkehren will muss sich an zwei
gehalten
2g bedeutet auch dass abstandsregeln
entfallen das disc ist ein kleines
restaurant und so war es hier keine
wirklich freie entscheidung
wir haben uns jetzt für die zweige
regelung entschieden nicht weil wir
irgend jemand ausschließen wollen
sondern einfach weil wir ein relativ
kleines restaurant sind wir haben 45
sitzplätze und bei 3g regelungen würden
wir die hälfte aller plätze verlieren in
dieser bar haben sie sich explizit für
2g entschieden durch das optionsmodell
aber habe die politik mal wieder
verantwortung abgewälzt
ich bin trotzdem enttäuscht ich finde es
sollte dann eine klare regelung geben
und für mich wäre diese regelung hat
eine zweijährige was sagen die
nachtschwärmer in meckel und jetzt zweig
lieber einfach dafür ich mich sicherer
ich finde das 3g auch völlig in ordnung
würde es jetzt im zweier angehen gehen
finde ich auch zweig auf jeden fall
richtig finde das auch okay ist wenn man
drei gemacht weil ich finde dass haben
sich jetzt schon einige impfen lassen
und wenn jeder sollte für sich selbst
entscheiden können ein oktoberfest nur
für geimpfte der wird bekam prompt einen
sturm hass kommentare man hat mir alles
gewünscht was man mir nicht wünschen
sollte aber dafür wir sind wir haben
breites kreuz und im nächsten jahr
können dann hoffentlich wieder alle
zusammen feiern mit nur einem gen für
gute laune auf
der kanaren insel la palma dauert der
vulkanausbruch an wegen der belasteten
luft durften tausende anwohner ihre
häuser zeitweise nicht verlassen grund
sind möglicherweise schädliche gase erst
gestern hatten sich ein neuer schlot
aufgetan die zahl der durch die
lavaströme zerstörten gebäude ist auf
mehr als 1000 gestiegen das auswärtige
amt rät von nicht notwendigen reisen
nach la palma ab
die gewinnzahlen vom lotto lauten ohne
gewähr 47 10 15 43 46 superzahl 4
weitere gewinnzahlen auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 5 56 und das
wetter morgen am tag der deutschen
einheit wird
herbstlich wechselhaft im westen meist
stark bewölkt und teils kräftiger regen
sonst bleibt es trocken und vor allem im
südosten scheint auch länger die sonne
bei starkem bis stürmischem südwind und
17 bis 26 grad in der neuen woche bleibt
es bei der mischung aus etwas sonne und
zeitweisem regen bei höchstwerten
zwischen 11 und 20 grad
so viel weiter geht es gleich mit dem
aktuellen sportstudio und direkt danach
meldet sich carsten rüger mit einer
heute express morgan auf wiedersehen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]